Speaker 1: as we wait to see whether Donald Trump
will be arrested and indicted in New York. We
have new news out of Georgia that there may be
potential racketeering and conspiracy charges
there coming against the failed former
president Donald Trump. This is again,
the belief about mounting legal troubles without
yet even knowing whether the New York indictment
is going to happen. Now, before I get into the
CNN report about what we have learned. I want to
remind people that one of the possibilities, if
and when the New York indictment of Trump comes
down, which Trump said would be today, certainly
not seeming like it's going to be today, but we
will follow it. One of the reactions was it's kind
of a weak charge. It's not the strongest charge
that could be made against Trump. And I agreed
with that. And the hope was that we know there
have been prosecutors who, despite having great
evidence against Trump, have been hesitant to be
the first to indict a sitting or former president
and now a former president. Is it possible that
the Stormy Daniels charges will break the levy and
then we will see other indictments come in? That's
the hope. And if that's the case, CNN reports that
Georgia prosecutors are considering racketeering
and conspiracy charges. And this is all related to
Trump's effort to overturn the results in Georgia
in the 2020 election, where, of course, Joe Biden
won because Joe Biden received more votes. CNN
reports Atlanta area prosecutors are considering
racketeering and conspiracy charges. Fulton County
District Attorney Fani Willis could make decisions
on charges this spring. Willis will bring her
charging recommendations to the regularly seated
grand juries, each serving two month terms to
regular grand juries were seated in March. The
next batch will be sworn in in May. Investigators
have at least three recordings of Trump pressuring
Georgia officials, including a phone call that he
made to the Georgia House speaker to push for a
special session to overturn Democrat Joe Biden's
2020 victory. There's also a recording of
Trump's call to a top investigator with
the Georgia secretary of state's office, where
they were looking into quashed allegations of
irregularities with signature matching. And then,
of course, Willis kicked off the investigation
soon after the infamous January phone call
wherein Trump pressures Brad Raffensperger to
find the votes necessary for him to win. This is
the next layer. Media eight also reporting Trump's
legal woes go from bad to worse, as CNN reports,
potential RICO charges for pressuring Joe. Georgia
election officials. So what do I believe is going
to happen? I have no idea. As I've said for a long
time, I believe indictments are plausible and
prison time is essentially an impossibility for
Donald Trump. I've explained why numerous times,
so I won't do it here. This is very serious stuff.
There is no doubt that these are potentially very
serious charges. At the same time, many of you,
like me, have been stuck in this sort of time
loop where we're always close to possible charges,
possible charges stemming from this or that
blatant violation of a law that we read about
and yet, quote, Nothing happens. On the one hand,
I feel that frustration. I share that frustration.
And there is a feeling that this is just never
going to happen. On the other hand, when you speak
to legal experts, they do say these things take
a while. Oftentimes when you look at white collar
crimes by non presidents, just by, you know, a CEO
of a tech company or a bank or whatever the case
may be, it can take years to build these cases.
Here. We're talking about a man who was and is now
a former sitting president. And so the timeline
is not actually that unusual. It's just that in
most cases, we're not following investigations
and we're not aware of possible charges until
much closer to when those charges are announced.
So I am not really taking a position as to whether
I do or don't think any particular indictment or
charge or arrest is going to happen. Trump said he
was getting arrested today. It doesn't seem like
it's happening. And now the discussion is about
either tomorrow or next week. I don't know. I
remain convinced, convinced that Trump will never
see the inside of a prison cell and that the big
picture of that is that at the very worst case,
if there were a plea or a guilty verdict and there
were to be confinement allocated or assigned to
Trump, it would be served as home confinement.
I think that that is the absolute worst case
scenario. But we're not even at that step yet.
We are now at this step of there are four at
least major investigations into Trump. Will any
of them lead to an indictment or an arrest? We
may know within hours. We may know tomorrow.
We may know next week. But the big news from
the last 24 hours is whatever happens with
this New York Stormy Daniels hush money case,
it is not the end of the line, as Georgia, I have
believed, is the strongest case for a while now.
And it seems as though the most serious charges
could indeed come from there. Leave me a comment.
Let me know at this point in time. In your
heart of hearts, what do you expect is coming?